if i asked you what the language of
mexico was you would probably say
spanish and you wouldn't be wrong
because spanish is the most widely
spoken language of mexico but it's not
the only one 68 national languages are
recognized by the mexican government
including 63 indigenous languages the
most widely spoken indigenous language
is nawatul or nawat
i'll explain this consonant represented
by tl in a minute nawat is a member of
the uto-aztecan language family which
has languages spoken in mexico and the
western united states there are many
dialects or varieties of nawat and they
are often considered distinct languages
that form a branch of yuto azteken the
nawan branch
when you see information about nawat
online or in books it's usually
classical nawat which was spoken by the
aztec or meshika people around the 13th
century when they migrated southward to
central mexico and some of them as far
south as nicaragua then in the 15th
century they established the aztec
empire based in tenochtitlan present-day
mexico city and with the expansion of
their empire came the expansion of the
nawat language classical nawat is no
longer spoken or used in writing but
various varieties of modern nawak
developed from it you could say it's
similar to how the modern romance
language is developed from latin nawat
can be divided into four dialect groups
central and northern western and eastern
one feature that distinguishes these
dialects is the pronunciation of the
phoneme represented in writing by tl in
central and northern nawat it retains
its classical sound
so the name of the language is
pronounced nawat this is a consonant not
found in english or spanish or most
other languages a voiceless alveolar
lateral affricate you make this sound by
positioning your tongue as though you
are making an l sound but you block the
airflow then release some constricted
airflow over the sides of your tongue
in eastern it has come to be pronounced
so the name of the language is
pronounced nawat in western nawat it has
come to be pronounced
so the name of the language is
pronounced nawal the degree of mutual
intelligibility is low between some
varieties while varieties geographically
close to each other tend to have high
mutual intelligibility the modern
variety that we'll focus on in this
video is orisaba nawat spoken in the
mountainous sierra de zangolica area
south of the town of orisaba this
variety has features of both central
nawat and eastern nawak this phoneme is
pronounced
like in central nawat
phonology nawat has four vowel phonemes
with short and long equivalents of each
though in orisaba
this short long distinction has to a
large extent been lost also note that
the o phoneme has an allophonic variant
that is more like
the phoneme is pronounced as in some
localities and
in others which you might expect to be
written as v so orisaba nawat often
prefers the w spelling over h u because
h u is too far removed from the letter v
which better represents the
pronunciation
the letter x represents the consonant
shi which normally isn't used in spanish
there are no voiced stops
there's also no f
which comes after vowels at the ends of
words for instance in some varieties and
in classical nawat it's a glottal stop
but in orisaba it's normally pronounced
some consonants are represented by
digraphs
which you're familiar with by now you'll
often notice this particular consonant
digraph at the end of nouns since it
functions as the most common absolutive
suffix a singular noun in nawak has an
absolute form when it's not in a
possessive form and not part of a
compound noun for example the word for
man
the base word is
and it's in the absolute form it's also
at the end of the language's name now
what the base word is now
basic grammar a sentence in nawat can
consist of a single word a verb with its
prefixes and suffixes noun phrases and
all independent pronouns can be absent
for example
this word means i saw them the verb base
is itta o is a past tense marker it's
used in many varieties of nawat and in
some cases optionally but in orisaba
nawat it's required for all past tenses
preterite imperfective and past perfect
ni is a subject pronoun prefix meaning i
kim is a third person plural object
pronoun prefix in other words it means
them the k marks the third person while
im marks the plural
is a preterite marker in other words it
marks the simple past tense the plural
form is different and the preterit
marker differs depending on the class of
verbs
if the sentence contains explicit
subjects or objects or additional
information it can have more words
this means i saw your parents at your
home nay is a standalone subject pronoun
meaning i which is optional the subject
pronoun prefix ni is attached to the
verb so the standalone pronoun isn't
required
when there are standalone subject and
object pronouns or explicit subjects and
objects modern varieties of nawa tend to
have svo word order subject verb object
this is partly due to the influence of
spanish and is different from the sov
and vso word orders which were common in
classical nawat but modern varieties
don't always use svo and there's
flexibility in the word order
next moapas means your parents mo is the
second person singular possessive prefix
in other words your and apas means
parents and comes from spanish papas
then there's mochan which means your
home or your residence again mo is the
possessive prefix you can see the rest
of the possessive prefixes on the chart
here
as i mentioned before this contains the
preterit tense or simple past tense
suffix
this is suffixed to the verb's
perfective base or base two there are
three different verb bases that are used
depending on the tense though in some
cases they take the same form as each
other depending on the verb if we wanted
to use the imperfect tense we would need
to use the verb's imperfective base or
base one for this verb it's the same as
base two from a moment ago in orisaba
nawat the o prefix is used here as well
but a different suffix is used
yeah
this also means i saw them but is
imperfective meaning it was ongoing over
a period of time
without the prefix o and the suffix yah
this word would be in the present tense
i see them the verb base for present
tense is the same imperfective base base
one then there's the future tense the
future tense uses base three which is
used for future or hypothetical verb
forms but again in some cases it's the
same as one or both of the other bases
let's look at a different sentence in
the future tense nikala
this means i will enter his house or her
house again we see the subject pronoun
prefix and here is the verb base and
here the suffix
is the future tense suffix
means his house or her house kal means
house and e is the third person singular
possessive prefix
if you want to show possession with an
explicit possessor you keep the
possessive prefix but add the possessor
before it
meaning his house becomes quanical
meaning juan's house nicolas
i will enter juan's house
when the subject is third person
singular there's no subject pronoun
prefix
he wants to sleep literally he wants it
he will sleep the verb base meaning want
here is nikki so if there's no subject
prefix what's the k prefix here that's
the third person singular object prefix
this verb is transitive so it needs an
object prefix even though the object
comes right after it the first verb here
is in the present tense the second verb
is in the future tense again there's no
subject pronoun prefix
there's the verb base meaning to sleep
and the future suffix
in the english sentence there's an
infinitive form to sleep but nawat
doesn't have an infinitive form
imperatives the imperative prefix she is
used before the verb base
the verb base is qua so what's this
is an unspecified object prefix like
things or something this is a transitive
verb so it needs an object prefix of
some sort if there's no specific object
you can use an unspecified object prefix
like this of course there could be a
different object prefix if it's
referring to something specific
eat it this is the same prefix she with
a third person singular object pronoun
after it there's also an honorific
suffix that can be used for the
imperative forms
the plural imperative is made by adding
the suffix
note that y'all comes from you all and
is not used in standard english but is a
way of using the second person plural in
english
eat it or eat it y'all
object pronoun prefixes can also be
added to imperatives
help us or help us y'all
tech is an object pronoun prefix meaning
us
this imperative is negative
don't eat a lot of meat word for word
it's not much meat eat it plural
imperative form
there are two negation markers used in
urisaba
this is used in non-declarative
sentences in other words imperative or
subjunctive sentences or questions match
this is used in declarative sentences
like regular statements for example much
negan against
i don't want to eat or i don't want to
eat anything word for word it's not i
want it i will eat something the use of
these negation words differs from place
to place and in some places only amo is
used
adjectives most adjectives are derived
from nouns or verbs through affixation
though others are standalone adjectives
for example there's the noun
meaning stone this word consists of the
noun stem te plus the absolute suffix
then there's the adjective
meaning hard this word consists of te
plus the suffix teak teak is the most
common adjective suffix but there are
others as well
means salt and
means white
is another adjective suffix
is a verb meaning he died
means dead ki is a past tense suffix but
when used at the end of an adjective
it's like a past participle in other
words with a passive meaning
in a noun phrase the adjective usually
comes after the noun
a white stone but it can come before the
noun for extra emphasis
the plural forms of adjectives usually
have the suffix ke which replaces
white stones here we see that the plural
noun can take the plural suffix me which
is normally used for monosyllabic noun
stems and those ending in a vowel and
there's another one t
used for other noun stamps the absolute
suffix is removed and meh is added
another example
meaning woman becomes sibami meaning
women
there are some other less common plural
suffixes as well choco means teenager or
young man its plural form is
another case in which the absolute of
suffix is dropped is when one noun
connects to another one to form a
compound noun for example we have the
name of the language nawat there's also
this word which means the now what
language
it consists of the noun stem
with the absolute suffix removed plus
the word
which means language or word the li at
the end of the word is an absolute
suffix so in a compound noun like this
there can be just one absolute suffix at
the end after the final noun component
another similar example
this means an indigenous person le is
the absolute suffix we can remove it and
make a compound noun
this means indigenous language but can
be used to refer specifically to nawat
and we can remove the absolute suffix
from this word and make it part of a
compound noun
this means translator this word consists
of
meaning language or word plus quepa
meaning to turn or transfer plus ni
which means he who does in other words
the doer of an action
because of extensive contact between
nawat and spanish for several centuries
it's not surprising that there are lots
of spanish loanwords in nawat here are a
few basic examples cafe meaning coffee
meaning horse another word for horses
which means beast in spanish
meaning tissue from spanish panuello
this comes from senora and means miss or
lady but is often used in a
disrespectful way to talk about less
traditional women who live in the city
you may not be aware of it but there are
actually a number of words of nawat
origin that we commonly use in english
some of them are coyote from
avocado from
as you can see nawat is an incredibly
interesting language it's likely very
different from your native language but
it's also very logical and
straightforward the trouble with
learning it as far as i can see mainly
comes down to which variety to learn
since classical nawaz is not spoken
anymore and there are many varieties of
modern nawat which have no real
standardized form and even when you
choose a variety to learn you may have
trouble finding resources i've met
people who've learned nawaz to an
advanced level and they achieved that by
living in a nawat speaking part of
mexico and learning the local variety
the question of the day for speakers of
nawat how well are you able to
communicate with speakers of other
varieties of nawat what factors does it
depend on and to other people does nawat
have any features that are similar to
ones in your language what are they if
you like this video and you're
interested in mexico then check out my
video about mexico on my second channel
the geofocus channel click the link on
screen or in the video description and
it's time to say thank you to the
langfocus patreon supporters especially
the ones who appear on the screen they
are the top tier patreon supporters so
many extra special thanks to them check
out patreon.com langfocus to see how you
can become a patron
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]
you